So I am the Web Accessibility Specialist
here at Stanford.
I work out of the University of
Communications.
I work with Scott Stocker, for any folks
who may know who he is.
He's been at Stanford for a number of
years, so lots
of folks know who he is which helps me in
my work.
And what my work consists of is a couple
of different things.
One thing is that I assess Stanford
websites, particularly
focusing on high traffic sites and high
visibility sites.
Assess them against the web content
accessibility guidelines.
Stanford focuses on it, it's called WCAG
for short.
You may hear people pronounce it
differently,
but WCAG, mostly people know what you
mean.
WCAG 2.0, and we focus on the Double A
Criteria.
I'm not gonna launch into any discussion
of those criteria, what they mean.
But, the short version to think about when
you think about WCAG is pour, P-O-U-R.
Perceivable, perceivable,Operable, ew.
>> Understandable.
>> Thank you [LAUGH] Understandable and
Robust.
Was that my colleague there, JB, in the
back?
>> Yeah, hi.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So anyway, so those are the four, four
criteria.
I don't actually think about them that way
very
often, cuz I kinda know em back and forth.
So that's, that's why I'm a little
[INAUDIBLE].
So I work on, assessments.
>> I'm going to give you a mic.
>> Oh.
That'll be good.
Can you hear me.
There we go.
I'll try not to make my voices.
Is this okay, okay good.
So, I work on assessing websites and I
also am building.
And it is a journey [LAUGH] to build
a website for the Stanford Online
Accessibility Program.
And we call that here SOAP.
So it's soap.stanford.edu.
And you're welcome to take a look around
and the
content will be growing as fast as I can
write it.
And get it posted.
So that's pretty much the work that I'm
doing people
that are, those, for those that are
students here at Stanford.
There's a different office that would be
available to help
you with accessibility needs in terms of
working with assistive technology.
In terms of working with to get your, to
get your documents, for example, in
accessible formats to you.
If you, if you needed a different format,
that kinda thing, that's The Office of
Accessible Education.
So there's, they're sorta the, the
website aspect of it and then there's more
the assistive technology aspect of things.
So just wanted to give you a bi, bit of a
rundown, bit of an orientation of what
we're doing here at Stanford.
I have just, my job has just expanded.
Become a Stanford staff member as opposed
to a contractor.
And so, I'm just getting myself rev'ed up
here.
That just happened in the last two weeks.
So I've got, got my work cut out for me.
We've got plenty to do.
I have no concern, frankly, about job
security [LAUGH].
There are lots of websites and, and things
to be looking at.
At the same time, we also have some good
strategies here at Stanford in place to
help assure accessibility.
One of those has to do, an, any of you all
heard of the Stanford Web Services?
The, group that has built a
druple, framework, basically that Stanford
can use.
And that framework has a lot of
accessibility features and functionality
built in for free.
And so, if people use Stanford sites, they
can you
can get it up and running with a website
really quickly.
And and get a lot of accessibility for
free.
So, I'm gonna wrap up, but I want to leave
you with two books.
And then, I want to take a little bit of a
quick poll in terms of, to find out who
you all are.
So, so that, so that, folks who come after
me will know who they're talking to.
So, books, I would recommend a recently
released book that I know Stanford has.
It is a Rosenfeld Media book.
Have you all heard of Rosenfeld Media?
You should, cuz they've got all the great
access, usability books.
And they also have a great
book where, we're having a sorta
crossover in interaction between
accessibility and usability.
Which I believe deeply in.
And that book is called A Web for
Everyone.
So it's available electronically from,
from the Stanford Library.
Authors, you'll recognize when you see
him.
Names are a little bit hard to spell.
Quesenbery.
Anybody heard of Whitney Quiz-,
Quesenbery?
Whitney Quesenbery and Sarah Horton.
So that's one book, and then the other one
was just crossing my mind when Michael was
introducing me.
So this is a quiz for anybody who can
remember.
There's this really good, user interaction
book, not so focused on
the web but focused more on products, and,
and that kinda thing.
It's by Graham Pullin.
Anybody know this book?
>> Yeah.
>> Can't remember the title.
>> Design Meets Disability.
>> That's right, that's right.
So that's a really good one if you haven't
taken a look, I
would say that it's sorta one of the
founding books in the field.
So make notes of this and there, there get
you off to a good start.
A Web for Everyone focuses a lot on
personas
of people with disabilities and how they
use the web.
So, that's what I got for you today and to
wrap up, like to take we're gonna do hand
raising for sighted folks and audio
queuing for blind folks.
Don't shout out.
Because, I mean, speak up, but it's not a
competition in terms of who wins.
So don't skew the results.
so, so how, general question, about how
many people in the room?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH].
Okay, I was gonna say are we having food
coma, I might be soon.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Friday.
Exactly, it is a Friday.
Okay, 60 or 70, okay students, raise hands
and give a little audio cue.
>> Here.
>> So about half.
Okay, Stanford staff.
>> Here.
>> And that includes faculty as well.
>> Good you guys are separate too.
Okay, excellent.
So does that pretty much cover everybody?
Oh public, we got some public people who
might have come.
>> Yeah, we're here.
>> That's us [LAUGH].
Okay, excellent.
Thank you guys for your time.
And I know we went over, but we're done.
I'm done and next person.
Think
I
hit it.
Okay, excellent.
All right.
Why don't I talk fast.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Okay, so the title of our topic is
Building an
accessible web, making sure that the web
is usable by all people.
Now before I go in and [INAUDIBLE] a
little more tangibly, I want
to try to root this topic of accessibility
within the context of CS547.
So, according to CS547's website, this is
a seminar about People, Computers, and
Designs.
And this is actually a really nice capture
of what accessibility is about.
Because accessibility intimately touches
each of these three things.
So we, when we use the term accessibility
in the context of technology.
We are typically talking about people with
disabilities interacting with computers.
And in order for people with disabilities
to interact with computers
successfully, in some cases, they need to
use a assistive technology.
Now one example of that, that we're gonna
focus on today is screen readers.
And that's a piece of assistive technology
that
blind people use to interact with the web.
The place where design comes in is that in
order for your experience, your web
experience that you're building.
The product that you're building, to be
usable,
by somebody, say, who is using a screen
reader.
You need to make conscious decisions,
about
how you design and engineer that web
experience.
You don't always just get accessibility
for free.
So, I've been talking pretty abstractly
for the past minute or so.
And it's not unreasonable that you might
feel a little bit like Austin here.
>> Whoopdy-doo!
What does it all mean, Basil?
>> What, what does this all mean, right?
What, what does it actually entail in
terms of trying
to make one's web experience accessible to
people with disabilities?
So, we're hopefully going to explain some
of that
today, over the course of the next 30
minutes.
Prove to you that you do need to make some
cautious
decisions, but also empower you guys to
know what to do.
Whether or not you are engineering a
website, designing a
website, doing research, from an HDI
perspective on a website.
It's important for each of these people
who
touch a product to understand a little bit
more.
About what accessibility is and what you
need to do to make something accessible.
In order for the web, in general, to
become more accessible.
So to make us a little less abstract.
And really make this a lot clearer to you
guys, I'm going to pass this over to
Victor.
And Victor's gonna walk you through what
the experience is like.
For somebody who is using a screen reader
to
interact with a computer and interact with
the web.
All right.
I need to come here, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> So let's adjust to your right here.
Here's the machine?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, awesome.
>> Okay, let's see, the mic working?
Hello, hello.
>> Yeah, think so.
>> [UNKNOWN] can you hear me?
>> It's a little bit soft.
>> Hello, can you hear me?
>> There we go.
>> All right, I didn't have my coffee,
sorry.
So hey guys, thanks for coming, this
always great to talk to students.
I've been one myself as you can imagine,
one day.
And especially that you're ATI people,
this is like even more amazing.
This is one of the areas that I personally
work in at PayPal.
But this is also the area where I spend
most of my life.
Is just making the darn computers interact
with me.
Right?
This is just as, as big of an ATI problem
as any other one.
And most of you interact with the world by
looking at things around you.
Everything is, you're being bombarded with
a lot of visual information.
So naturally, you visual sense is
overloaded.
And, but that's, unfortunately, pretty
much the most
you sense out of all that you have.
In my instance, I'm actually on the other
side
of the spectrum, which means I can't see
anything.
And that means that I'm not bombarded with
all the junk that you guys are.
This is a great thing.
I don't see all the freaking ads and
things like that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Another great thing I don't, you know,
I
don't, I don't see all the pop-ups and
animations.
But unfortunately, good or bad, they do
interfere with my experience.
And I'm gonna show you in this, in a
minute, why.
So how to interact with a computer?
I use technology that Jeff already
mentioned called ScreenReader.
ScreenReader is a slightly modif, a
slightly misleading
name because all of us are screen readers,
right?
You guys read screens, right?
Right?
So when I started back at the university,
I had a
lot of screen readers, people who would
read the screen for me.
Because at that time, there was no
computers that I could take advantage of.
But the, the technology I'm talking about
is actually
a software that is built into every modern
operating system.
Mac OS, Windows.
IOS, Android, you name it, they all have,
this software we call a screen reader.
And essentially the task of a screen
reader is to, to communicate
the, the information that appears on the
screen, to somebody who cannot see.
So.
[SOUND] This is done usually via, speech
synthesis.
And I want to separate those two things
for you right away
because most people think that speech is a
part of the screen reader.
This is exactly not, not exactly
correctly.
Speech synthesis is different from screen
reader
and, we'll find out in a moment why.
So, let me see.
I haven't used Jeff's computer before, so.
Let's see what's gonna happen here.
[SOUND]
>> Voiceover on Safari, Facebook window,
Facebook HTML [INAUDIBLE].
>> That's cool, all right.
So, back in 2005, I think or 2006, Apple
said that we can.
Make it possible for any blind user to
come up to any Apple
computer anywhere in the world, press a
shortcut key, and be ready to go.
[COUGH].
>> At that time what you had to do, and on
Windows, if
you're like, on anything before Windows 8,
you still have to do that.
You have to actually ask somebody to go
and download for you
the piece of software, help you install
it, launch it for you.
And only then, you'll be able to go ahead
and use the computer.
With Apple, all you need to know is
that when you press Cmd+F5, this thing
launches.
No matter what you do.
Are you, whether you're reading your
email, or you're
on, on Facebook or, you know, using Paypal
or whatnot.
It's gonna launch and it's going to start
talking to you.
So, from then on, most likely what's gonna
happen to you, is you're going to get
confused.
Cuz, you're like, I don't know what to do
with this thing.
Right?
Cuz, one of the things you'll find out the
screen reader, that not
only that it talks which, you probably
need to be able to understand.
But it also will in, in, interfere with,
with the way you use the computer.
I'm not gonna go into all the details,
because it's a
little bit, maybe more advanced for this
particular presentation today, but
suffice it to say that, in order to be
efficient in
using the screen reader, you need to know
how it works.
I mean, it sort of makes sense, right?
I mean, in order to be able to.
To drive to San Diego, you need to know
how the car works, right?
So, same way.
So, lear, learn the rules of the road.
So, the rules of the road for the screen
reader is
that, as a blind user, mouse is useless to
me, number one.
[COUGH].
>> So, anything I do on the web, or
anything I do on the desktop needs to be.
Available, accessible, reachable via
keyboard.
Most of you guys probably know the
keyboard, right?
How many keys you think you know on the
keyboard?
[INAUDIBLE].
>> What is the big, what is the biggest.
What is the, biggest key, on the keyboard?
>> Spacebars.
>> Oh, that was too quick.
[LAUGH].
>> What key do you need to press to
continue?
Oh, that's an old Microsoft joke.
Sorry.
Press any key to continue.
[LAUGH].
>> Okay, so.
[COUGH].
>> So, in my instance just to keep things
simple, I need to use mostly tab key
and arrow keys to be able to do
anything, well, not anything, most,
everything on a desktop.
There are other, short cuts that you'll
see me using.
They are specific to screen viewer.
And, by the way this particular screen
view is called voice over.
As I mentioned, it's built into every Mac.
So, this is great if you don't belive me
go to your closest Apple store
and, if you want to impress your partner
or, or or sales rep in the store.
Just press Cmd+F5 and like, hey, did you
know.
Anyway.
So.
>> [CROSSTALK] And don't forget to press
it to turn it off when your done too.
[LAUGH].
>> Well, I think that's not necessary.
Reaction.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> That's,that's fun if you don't
actually.
[LAUGH].
>> That is the coolest thing ever.
Okay, so, [SOUND] I'll go to the desktop.
The first thing I'm gonna do, is I'll slow
this thing down.
As you can imagine just like with the car.
There are people who drive slowly, there
are people who
drive like crazy, and there are people in
the middle.
That's the same way we read with the
screen reader, right?
Speech is a very personal thing.
Some people talk fast, some people listen
fast.
And so, in order for me to be able to
interrupt with the screen I
kind of need to find what's the most,
what's the most appropriate thing for my
particular.
Ability to listen.
Most people.
[SOUND].
Most people listen to something like that.
All right.
Did you get it?
[LAUGH].
>> Okay, cool.
So, for you guys, I'm gonna [SOUND] slow
it down.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Just because I'm a really nice person,
so.
>> [INAUDIBLE] 50%, 35%.
>> All right.
[LAUGH].
>> Actually, you know, this is.
>> Ten, [SOUND] 1%.
[LAUGH].
>> You've got lots of time, right?
Do you.
[LAUGH].
>> We can sit here and listen.
Okay.
Anyway I'll go back to something more,
nominal.
>> 46%, 36%, 41%.
>> Okay, tell me this is too fast and we
can switch.
So, I've got this thing, I've got this
thing talking
to me and you know I can switch the speed.
And again, I just want to repeat this
because, in
the field of HCI it's super important to
be personalizable, right?
And so, the same thing with the screen
reader
is a piece of tech, a piece of software
and
I want to be able for it to work for me as
opposed for me to work for it.
RIght, and who's the master here after
all?
So, so I set it to the speed I want.
The other thing with speech synthesis you
can do because
again, some voices are better other voices
are, not as good.
So, with the screen reader I can go ahead
and say, you know, I.
>> Pitch 50 [INAUDIBLE] voice Alex, Bruce.
>> Like different voice.
>> Fred.
Kelly.
>> Anyone here, loves Radiohead.
>> Kelly.
>> Alex, Bruce, Fred.
>> They use this voice I think on their OK
computer album.
>> [SOUND] Personal Folder.
>> So, if you don't believe me go back and
check it.
It's really cool.
[LAUGH].
>> It's a really old like Mac OS,
[CROSSTALK] Mac OS 9 or something like
that.
>> Voice, Kelly.
>> Alex.
>> Anyway, so they're high quality voices.
They're like sort of, low quality in
something between.
You can purchase them.
The most recent Mac OS comes with, like,
25 what, voices in 25 different languages.
And with different genders, and, I mean,
it's amazing.
You can really adjust experience anyway
you want.
You know, just the same way,
>> [UNKNOWN] 41 pitch 50%.
>> You can go and change the pitch.
>> 75%.
[LAUGH].
>> [SOUND] 40%.
30%.
15%.
5%.
>> Okay, this dude is really serious now.
[LAUGH].
>> So.
>> 35 per, 50%.
Volume, 100%.
>> And, you know, there's all kinds of
other stuff.
So, there's volume, and blah, blah, blah.
So,
let's, let's do this no actually I'm gonna
postpone this exercise for, for, for a
second.
So to navigate on, on a, for example, on a
dock or on desktop, I would be using tab
key.
Or arrow keys.
And I expect the screen viewer to give me
a feedback.
>> Dark.
Finder.
Open.
One.
>> Now, one thing about, voice over that
you guys may, have noticed already.
>> Muting.
>> Let me just double check that's.
>> Show braille panel.
Hide braille pane- [SOUND].
The voice over quick start in this.
>> Sorry.
>> Voice over on, finder.
Desktop.
[INAUDIBLE].
High caption panel.
>> Whoops.
Where is this caption thing?
Here we go.
>> Show caption panel.
>> Okay, I, I don't, Jeff on your screen
where it
appears on the left side, I think is but,
tradition where this.
You will, you will also see like a visual
line, that's telling you.
It's telling you in text what the screen
reader is saying.
[COUGH].
>> Don't assume that this is the behavior.
This is just, Apple is trying to be cool.
Which is great, also for educational
purposes
because if somebody is deaf, and they
cannot
hear a screen reader, they can sit down
with somebody who is using a screen
reader.
And being able to, you know, either work
on the homework together or, just
interrupt, or whatever.
It is a pretty nice feature.
Also a great feature for developers.
In fact, a quick story that I heard from,
this is authentic.
I hard it from people who worked in Voice
Silvers that.
The way visual panel was born, is that it
was actually originally
used for debugging purposes because
engineers
hated to listen to these, synthetic
voices, and so they figured out, hey, why
don't we just take
the algorithm of the skin and just put it
in the screen.
And then, the product manager walked in
and said, what the hell are you doing.
And I was like, oh, don't worry, it's
gonna
be gone by the time it goes into beta.
It won't be there.
And she was like, wait a second what is
this.
She looked at me, she liked the features
so
much we are gonna leave it in the product.
And so it ended up a really cool thing,
develop, developers love it.
And, for you guys, when you start using a
screen reader, maybe just
something that's gonna help it make it
easier for you to, to interact initially.
So, back to the dock.
So, I'm gonna be using left and right
arrow keys,
and.
>> [SOUND] Dock.
>> Oh, sorry, he's got a vertical dock,
now I remember.
>> Trash, 20 of 20.
>> So, I'm using the up and down arrow
keys.
To, move between the items and the dock.
>> Finder, open 1 of 20.
System preferences, 2 of 20.
Launchpad, 3 of 20.
Dashboard, 4 of 20.
>> So, pretty simple, right?
It tells you what, icon you're on.
Anybody who is not familiar-.
>> [CROSSTALK] You are currently on the
dashboard.item.
To open dashboard, press Ctrl.
>> Anybody else who's not familiar with
accessibility, can you, did you
notice anything else, except, the name of
the icon when it was spoken.
I'll give you one more hint.
>> Microsoft Outlook, 5 of 20.
>> Anything?
[LAUGH].
>> So, so it said, said Microsoft
Outlook and then [CROSSTALK] it said
something else.
>> [CROSSTALK] You are currently on the
dashboard.item.
To open this application.
>> It said Microsoft Outlook and then it
said something else.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> 5 or 20, right?
So, why is this important to know?
[SOUND].
>> Come on be brave.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> I know it's supposed to be a
presentation but you know,
my presentations are always like that, so,
in case, you didn't know.
So anyway.
[COUGH].
>> So, the idea is to let the screen
reader, user
know about the size of the, control we're
dealing with, right?
So, in this case, we have 20 icons and,
we're on icon number 5.
So, it does help you to get oriented to a
little bit.
So if, in case you know that your mail
icon is at the beginning of the doc.
You know, you're not going to go to Item
19,
and then wrap around, but you're going to
go backward.
Cuz, item 1 is closer to 5.
So, somebody clearly thought about that
kind of stuff.
And, and you know, it appears to be very
useful.
Before we get onto dock.
>> Dashboard, launch pad, system prep,
finder, open, 1 of 20.
What, what about this one?
Finder, did you hear words.
You are currently on the application.
[INAUDIBLE] finder, open.
>> It said, finder, open, that's pretty
neat right?
>> You are currently on the
application.item.
>> [CROSSTALK] So, we'll see if I went to.
>> To open this aplication [INAUDIBLE]
safari, open eight.twen-.
>> As opposed to.
>> Firefox, 7of 20.
>> Its pretty cool, right?
So, it tells you which of the windows is
currently open.
So.
>> You are currently on application.item.
To open this application, press.
>> And this is the, this is what happens
when you're
in beginner mode, it gives you all these,
hints and stuff.
so, this is pretty cool, right?
Again, great for somebody who cannot see,
because
for you guys who take this for granted.
You look at this screen and you're like, I
know which windows are open, right?
For me, I can go, I can have to go through
each
of these elements and try to figure out so
what exactly is open.
Okay, let's move on one step further.
So, there comes a time where, arrow keys
and tab keys aren't gonna do cuz,
you know, you need to be, doing more
complex operations than just, moving
between your items.
So, for example, you need to be able to
switch between windows.
So, we know there are at least two
windows, open on the screen.
Find it in safari, so so rely on me,
command tab will allow us to move between
windows.
So, that's a built in Mac shortcut key
that we gonna use.
So, let's see what happens there.
>> Safari, Keynote, finder.
Safari, Keynote, finder.
>> Okay.
Cool.
So, there's actually one more window open,
right?
Which is Keynote, his presentation.
So, how do I know that the Keynote is
open?
There's a window.
You notice there's a title in the window.
Every window has this title area.
Where it tells you, what's the name of the
app is,
especially on the web, we'll see instances
where, people forget to put
the title, and so when you move between
tabs in the
browser, or you move between Windows, and
if there's no title there.
Then obviously, as a blind user, you have
no idea, what you're talking, what you're
interacting with.
So, simple thing like titling your window,
gives the
metadata for a screen reader to, announce
something useful.
Now, interesting enough, in Keynote's
case.
>> [SOUND] Safari, key note.
Keynote, Stanford CS547 window slide nav.
>> That's cool, right?
So, I know what presentation he's do,
he's, he's showing us.
What presentation Jeff has opened so this
is nice, without having to do
anything, because the title, is
communicating
to me the name of the document.
[COUGH].
>> Finder.
Safari.
Safari, tracing message new window,
heading level one length.
Based.
>> Cool.
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGH].
>> Okay, this is great.
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGH].
>> Yeah.
Oh, oh.
>> Hopefully he says nice things.
>> Yeah, he does.
[LAUGH].
>> Yeah, don't provoke him.
>> So, okay, cool.
So, as you can see, the context is very
important.
This is the title of the window, and, so
to finish the desktop, [CROSSTALK] part of
this presentation.
>> Keynote, finder, find.
>> Similarly, you know, if you go to the
menu.
>> Menu bar [INAUDIBLE].
Finder.
>> I'm just using arrow keys right now.
>> File.
Okay.
So I found the File menu.
>> File menu, 25 items.
>> You heard that before, right?
So, it informs me that there's 25 items in
the menu.
>> You are currently on a menu.
To choose this menu item press Ctrl.
>> And a lot of the other transactions you
will be doing with the
keyboard, through the keyboard will be
pretty
much what you guys would be used to.
Enter key to activate stuff.
You know, arrow keys to move left and
right, up and down, so on and so forth.
So what I wanna do [CROSSTALK] I'm known
to to go over time,
and I didn't ask anybody to alert me when
the time is, arrived.
So, what I'm gonna do is moved to the web.
A little bit to talk about the web and
then we're
gonna move in to the topic that excites me
personally because I
worked a lot on mobile stuff and that is
really you know,
what gets me going and wakes me up in the
morning, literally.
Anyway [LAUGH] okay, so on the web,
similar just like we
have on the desktop, we have to interact
with a webpage.
mostly, well not mostly, but by default.
You, you'll be using Tab key to navigate.
That will move you between focusable
elements on the page.
You'll hear the word focus, especially
those of you.
How many programmers, by the way, are in
the room?
Are there any developers here?
Applaud, [SOUND] not to me, to yourself.
Okay good awesome so there's some
developers.
So you hear the word focus being
mentioned in the context of accessibility
many, many,
many, many, many times, focus events you
know, objects under focus and things like
that.
Very important.
Why it's important.
>> Track pad, screen curtain on.
>> Okay, so I'm here on this web page.
And you guys don't see anything, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Me too.
>> So how do you know where on the screen
I'm, I currently am?
Anybody?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> No, of course, I know.
I'm just tricking you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's impossible, right?
Because now your, your contextual
information
is gone, your two-dimensional vision is
gone,
and so what you are stuck with is what I
call is one-dimensional vision.
And that is basically a linear way to
interact with a computer.
Luckily the situation has changed a little
bit
with the introduction of tight screens,
but on
the desktop we're still largely talking
about one
dimension, especially as far as the
keyboard is concerned.
So let's say I took you to a page.
>> New tab, now in all my.
[NOISE].
>> Questions for Jeffery Microsoft Word
Document One.
Safari, Safari One.
New Tab, Untitled.
Search Google or enter an address.
Address in search edit text.
>> Where do you think I am.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> You are currently on a text field
inside of a toolbar.
>> Well okay, Google maybe, but that's
only because Google is
built into the browser, but I'm actually
on the Address Bar, right?
That's, that's a fair guess.
So let's do something.
>> Open location at period, O, M,
un-highlight.
>> Okay, [CROSSTALK] which page do you
think I'm on?
You wouldn't know.
So, so this is the typical experience of
somebody who is blind.
I'm gonna refresh this page so you guys
can actually hear
the title of the page and this way you
will know.
>> Reload page.
CNN.
87% loaded.
Visited link image CNN.
List 4.
Screen curtain off, display bright.
Bright.
CNN.com breaking news.
U.S. world weather.
Entertainment and video news window.
So that's the title of the page.
Okay?
So you kind of know that I am on CNN.com,
right?
What else do you know about this?
Not much, because we're right now on the
page, and I as a
blind person have no idea about things on
the left, on the right.
I have no idea where those stories appear.
So the way that I deal with this situation
is
that you start gathering, you start
mapping out the screen.
Little by little.
So you start tabbing.
>> Link, link, international, CNN
International, link, Mexico,
CNN Mexico, link, Arabic, CNN Arabic,
link, TV, list five items.
Link CNN, CNN TV program, link CNE, CNN
link, CNN on.
>> Okay, before you fall asleep, so so
were going
through some kind of tool bar, right and
so if
you just imagine, I'll just let you use
for the
rest of this exercise, I'll just let you
use your imagination.
You literally have to go through the page.
If you're a beginner especially, you have
to go through this page.
It's like looking through a straw.
You know?
You.
You slowly move a straw across the screen,
like, oh, okay.
Now I start getting it.
So on the left side or maybe first comes
the Menu bar.
Then second comes.
Eventually we're gonna get, like, to top
stories.
And then we're gonna get to probably some
kind of advertising.
And then we're going to get to some kind
of footer, right?
So this is basically how a ScreenReader
user works to learn about webpage.
Now, we have this language, and I'll, I'll
hopefully I'm not gonna steal
thunder from Ramiel, but I have to mention
a couple of these things.
So, we have the language of the web called
HTML
and HTML lets us mark up our page in such
a
way as to make it easier for somebody like
a ScreenReader
user to dissect the page and avoid all
this repetitive tabbing.
So you do this only when you absolutely
have
to but if the page is marked up correctly.
You can actually you can reduce the time
that you
have to spend tabbing through the page,
because HTML gives
us features like HTML Headings, we've got
Form fields, we
have lists, and so if we use all this HTML
correctly.
And provide the necessary semantic
information.
The ScreenReader being software as it is,
can take advantage of that stuff.
It says hey, I'm smart.
I can figure that out.
I take a web page, I scan the down, I can
see the heading, I can see links.
Now, the heading of course is only.
A CSS heading, but you know, it's not
actual H tag, the ScreenReader,
as smart as it is, it would know that it's
actually a heading.
So to show what I'm talking about, I'm
gonna turn on, turn on the screen.
Let's see where's the tag.
>> It's there.
>> It's right there, cool.
Okay, here.
>> Green curtains on.
Voiceover muted.
>> Oops.
>> Voiceover, link, pay.
>> No.
Screen curtain off.
>> Okay cool.
Here I just wanted to double check.
So what I'm going to do, I use this
feature of of
voice over is to show you like a quick
overview of this page.
>> Headings 37 items.
>> And you guys should see that right?
So there's a list of headings and as a
ScreenReader user I can go
through this list and actually decide
which of the headings I really care about.
>> 4, BREAKING NEWS.
1, link, MERS reaches U.S. 1, link, First
U.S. case of deadly virus is reported in
Indiana.
4, THE LATEST.
>> Okay.
So you've notice that also in next to the,
to each heading there's a number, right?
One, four, three, two and so on and so
forth.
This page, by the way, is [NOISE] poorly
structured.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But that's, that's a, that's separate
stories.
We're gonna cut this out from YouTube
video.
Anyway, now, so, so, these are different
levels of headings, right?
Just like in Word document.
When you, if you guys create
bibliographies, or things like that.
Or, When, you know, when you have like,
chapters and sub-chapters and sections.
It's pretty much the same way, right?
Except with an HTML, we use.
Heading levels to indicate that, and yes,
there
are shortcut keys to let the users, once
they
know the page, once they learn it's
structure,
the shortcut keys to say hey, you know
what?
I know that my top stories begin with
heading level one, so I
just want to jump between those, I don't
care about other headings, okay?
So all of these things are available.
So I just pick one of these headings,
let's say,.
>> 4, BREAKING NEWS.
1, link, MERS reaches U.S.
>> Press Enter.
>> Heading level one link.
MERS reaches U.S..
>> And the focus jumps to that particular
place on the page, so.
>> You are currently on a heading level
one inside of an HTML.
>> So you can see just immediately how, by
using headings, I already cut down a
number of keystrokes that I have to press
just to get to the middle of the page.
So you know essentially there, you can see
that there are other things like.
>> Headings, links, 391 items.
>> Wow, see how many times you'd have to
tab, 391 and that's at best.
So there also are other shortcut keys to
get to
you because [CROSSTALK] obviously not
everything on the webpage is focusable.
There are some elements in the webpage
there are
there are pieces of text you know, like.
Subtitle of a story so there are shortcut
keys
to let you go through that so I have, I
can simply move further down [CROSSTALK]
okay, so let us
quickly, so this in in in principle how
ScreenReader works.
I'm gonna check out Jeff's, should I use
Safari or Chrome?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Okay.
>> Open loc, in, oh, peer, see,
un, select, see, period, cop,
unhighlighted, insertion.
[SOUND] Heading, link, Facebook.
>> So, without going to Facebook, many of
you guys are using Facebook.
I, I hear this.
>> You are currently on a heading level
one, inside of a HTML content.
>> This is where actually.
>> Ooh.
>> Enter.
Two message.
Link not found.
>> oh.
>> Next button.
Previous button.
[SOUND] Heading.
Link not found.
>> You got it?
>> Trackpad commander.
One Facebook link, Facebook, close tab,
twitter, new tab.
[CROSSTALK].
>> So yeah, I heard teenagers are.
>> You are currently on HTML content, to
enter the.
Or something else.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, we can use something else.
>> Open location.
Up [INAUDIBLE] O, M.
>> Sorry about me.
Jeff, I didn't mean to.
>> I ask you.
>> Password secure, sign in but.
Open.
W, O, M, slash, com, slash, A, A, L, L, B.
>> Alright.
>> Paddy level two visited link tweeter.
>> So so when we move into the world of
web apps obviously, not everything is
going to be as simple as just like
moving from link to link or moving between
headings.
And so, Twitter and Facebook and Gmail and
some other leading.
Providers have done some amazing job in
sort
of exploring, how can we take the web
further,
and not just sort of, for example, take
the
web further when have to deal with web
apps.
So for example in Twitter's case.
And Facebook is the same, but since you
know, Jeff
couldn't get it working, so they're kinda
like, in parallel.
They provide a lot of shortcut keys to let
the users
feel like they're using the actual app and
not just a website.
So, for example, in Twitter's case, I can
use.
Actually, let's, oh yeah, I can use first.
>> PayPal accessibility.
>> I can use letters J and K to more
between tweet feeds.
And the same thing on Facebook, you use J
and
K to move between posts, which is really,
really cool.
And you notice that ScreenReader will
actually announce.
All of this magic, of course, is done with
the help of Focus, right?
So every time the J key.
Moves the,
>> Retweeted by PayPal accessibility.
>> So the focus is being moved to that
object.
Right?
So in this, in this case it's gonna be a
tweet.
And I'm using similarly K and you guys,
those of you who use VIM.
Anybody use VIM?
Yeah, okay.
Wow, too few voices here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's okay cause I don't use it
myself, so.
[LAUGH] I have other editors I like.
So but anyway.
So it's a pretty Unix-y thing to do you
know G
N K and, but this is okay because this is
like.
You know on YouTube the same thing, you
can use J and L to
move backward and forward in the video,
and then K to stop and play video.
So this really helped so now we're moving
into the
space of, you know, not just being like a
regular
just looking at the regular website, but
also.
Working with more complex applications.
So if I wanted to know shortcut keys are
available on
Twitter, or on Facebook, anybody wants to
guess the shortcut key?
>> Figuring out the other shortcut keys?
>> Sorry?
>> The shortcut key for figuring out the
other shortcut key?
>> Yes.
>> Question mark.
>> You know, there's always the one key,
right?
I mean, you guys know about security.
There's got to be a public.
And private key.
Without those keys you can't get to the
rest.
So there is always one key you've got to
know.
Alright?
>> F1.
>> Good guess.
Anybody else?
>> Could someone.
>> Question mark.
>> What is that?
>> Okay, let's do it.
>> Keyboard shortcuts, alert dialogue,
close button.
>> Alright.
So, this thing popped up, it's got short
list of short cut keys and this.
[CROSSTALK].
>> You are currently on a button.
>> And also, you may have noticed that
ScreenReader
said something like alert dialogue which
is really important.
This is going a little bit more into,
beyond I think, advanced basic stuff.
But essentially one of the big problems on
the Web is that while on
a desktop you have a clear distinction
between what's a window and what's not.
Programmatically it's actually broadcasted
that there is a separate window.
On the Web we have only divs.
Right?
So people use divs and, like you, always a
separate divs or dot.
You know, make it look like a window since
it's a window, right?
But it's not the same for if you use the
ScreenReader because.
For ScreenReader, div doesn't mean
anything.
So there are certain super semantics we
can lay over in, in
the code to to communicate that hey this
is actually a pop-up dialogue.
Which is what exactly what happened in
this case.
Or I can just use you know, I'm looking
up.
>> Note to use these shortcuts users of
ScreenReaders may need to toggle off the
virtual navigate.
Enter.
[CROSSTALK].
>> Instructions.
Clickable.
F.
Clickable, go to user.
Clickable.
F, F.
>> And so on so forth.
You'd, you'd go and you'd study all the
shortcut keys.
But, yeah.
This is all you need to know.
Even on Facebook just press Question Mark
and the shortcut keys are there.
>> PayPal is.
>> So essentially just I'll.
Rahmi is gonna summarize some of the stuff
of the stuff that I was talking about.
But I wanna spend a bit of time on, on On
mobile, remember I told you that?
I'm gonna keep my word.
Where's this, where's this piece of
technology that I need to use.
Oh, cool.
Okay, let's hope nobody is gonna send me
any messages.
>> As long as it's here.
>> Okay.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay can you give me that, audio cable.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Oh it's in here right?
Yes so so in 2009 what would you mention
this company Apple, they
thought to crack the problem of making
touch screens accessible for blind people.
Cuz you know, it's so great when you use
a keyboard because you can feel each and
every key.
Or even in the case of Nokia, you can use
buttons or you know.
Sorry [INAUDIBLE] You know rim you know,
whatever the older phones right?
So what do we do with a touch screen?
So they had to figure out how to make the
touch screens talk.
Okay well the softer pattern wasn't all
that difficult so they took voice over.
That they have here.
They took it kind of ripped it apart you
know restructured and they put it in the
iphone.
Okay, that's great we got their first
step.
What is the biggest problem you guys are
s, smart people here right?
Those of you who don't know how, how touch
screens work.
What do you think is the biggest problem
in making touchscreens accessible for
somebody who's blind.
It has to do with gestures, I'll give you
a hint.
So you have a screen reader.
It'll talk, so we assume that.
What's the, what's the big thing?
It has to do something with the way you
gesture with the touchscreen.
>> Where do you press?
Okay, right.
So where do you press?
Okay.
So let's say I wanna find out where I
press.
What happens when I put my finger
on the screen?
>> [UNKNOWN] where your [INAUDIBLE] is?
>> [COUGH]
>> If you use [UNKNOWN], doesn't that
image [INAUDIBLE] once?
Do like you [INAUDIBLE] actually simply
execute
the adjustment instead of turning your
work [INAUDIBLE]
>> Do you guess that or do you know that.
>> Okay good.
Okay, well you saved everybody.
You know when the ship is you know, about
to
sink there's always somebody who's gonna
stay with the ship.
So congratulations you get a medal.
That's exactly what they had to figure
out.
Surprisingly enough it's very easy now for
us
to talk about it but supposedly up until
2009 with all the proliferation of mobile
phones,
nobody actually, even the first three
models of
Apples' iPhones, they came out without
pretty much
any accessibility in them so it was really
amazing when somebody said, actually we
can do
that and basically all they had to do.
Is to take over the gestures, so when you
launch Voiceover
on your iOS device it, it will take over
the gesture in
such as way that you touch once to hear
what you're
touching, and on the second, and touch,
touch twice to execute it.
So now.
>> 1:42 PM.
Friday.
May 7.
>> We're gonna make it louder, so.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
1:42 p.m.
>> Okay, is this?
>> Friday, May 2nd.
>> Oh, wait, you know what.
Give me a second.
>> Friday, May 2nd.
>> I forgot, I need to oh, these corporate
phones.
Actually, this surprise is not real-
>> [UNKNOWN].
>> [LAUGH].
You know why?
Because I think the speech takes quite a
lot
of battery too cuz it constantly keeps on
talking.
That would be great, actually.
>> [INAUDIBLE] reminders.
Double tap two of them.
>> So, the screen curtain is on.
>> Screen curtain [INAUDIBLE].
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> But can you just,
>> Characters, language.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Headings, containers, hints, sounds,
volume,
speech write [UNKNOWN] 50 perce, 45%, 40%.
>> Okay cool, okay now hopefully now you
guys can see.
So I single touch something.
>> Reminders.
>> [UNKNOWN] Double tap to open.
>> Then it gives me hint to double tap to
open.
So if I wanted to see.
I don't know.
Let's say reminders.
>> App store.
>> Actually, let's do App store.
>> Double tap to open.
App store.
Updates.
Heading.
>> You double tap, right?
From here on, you have two ways of
exploring the touch screen.
Now remember voiceover controls my
gestures.
So there is a way to ask voiceover to
bypass a gesture, means.
Don't know, let me the next gesture let,
pass it through directly to the app.
But by default most users wouldn't wanna
do that
because it's pretty dangerous unless you
know what you're doing.
So I can just start exploring the screen.
>> Updates, heading [INAUDIBLE] upda,
Instagram
[INAUDIBLE] Music, Version two [INAUDIBLE]
and
featured, tap [INAUDIBLE] Search,
selected, update,
search, uni [INAUDIBLE] featured, tap,
105.
>> Okay you notice right away what happens
there, right?
Is that I can suddenly start getting a
a spatial imaginational delay out of the
screen, right?
So I've got a Tab bar at the bottom, which
consists of five tabs.
>> Selected.
Updates.
Tab five of five.
>> Not only that, notice how voice over
tells me
which of them is currently active, right,
when it says selected.
>> NPR News.
Version three.
Featured.
Tab one of five.
Top charts tab, two of five near me tab,
three of five search.
>> So if I tap one of those, lets say
search.
>> Selected.
Search tab.
>> Now search becomes a selected tab, so
remember
how we talked about one dimensional
navigation on a desktop?
Well, finally with tablets and And touch
screens or the
screen reader, we can actually start
getting a little bit more
into, so can I start if I go to a
website and I learn that something is on
the left side.
I don't have to go like, one by one, I can
just scroll my finger.
>> Top charts tap selected search update
tap selected update beats mus instagram
beats side car beast mus instagram button
open button.
>> So that's one way, so you can drag your
finger and learn the layout of the screen.
You can also one of the things they've
done is that
they've said, well, you know, it's gonna
be hard for some
blind people to immediately readjust to
touch screens, so, we're gonna
give them a feeling as if they were using
a tab key.
So you can move through the hierarchy.
On the screen by, sudden anywhere on the
screen, and just, and just swipping.
>> [UNKNOWN] [NOISE]
>> It does take you a little longer.
But you know if you're in a hurry or if
you, you're just exploring or if let's say
you know, you're not comfortable in using
touch exploration
that's another way so you can swipe right
and left.
uni, tab [UNKNOWN]
>> Yes I'm almost done.
And so the last thing I wanted to show you
is that.
Is that so as you can imagine all of the
gestures, like single touch to to you
know, to, to hear.
Double touch to activate.
There's also of course, you can swipe left
and right.
>> Extras Folder.
Messages.
>> And so on and so forth.
>> Page 1 of 13.
iTunes Store.
Settings.
>> And so last thing I wanna show you guys
is where to find this.
>> General.
Button.
>> Because there is no reason, there is no
reason why.
You guys starting HGI should know how to
use this cool gadget right?
>> [UNKNOWN] Text size, Accessibility
[CROSSTALK].
>> And I think I'd mentioned a 100 times
but I'll just say it a 101st
but is that it's built into every, every,
every, every, every I device can you
imagine.
Every.
Apple 2B has something, some kind of that,
you
know I pod touch and I pad and I phone.
This voice zone.
This is, this is for voice over
[CROSSTALK] so if you want to
learn how to use voice over you go here
speaking right, speaking right.
>> Speed text.
Double.
Tap once to select.
>> It gives you very basic instructions
how to use voice over.
If you, if you are not comfortable getting
yourself into trouble you can always tell
Siri turn voice over on or turn voice over
off in IOS 7 point one I think, no IOS 7.
And that always gonna get you out of
trouble.
So since you know, we talked about desk
top we talked about mobile phones.
I want Rama to come up and talk a little
about the web.
And the reason why we spend so much time
talking about the web, companies like
Facebook and Twitter and Paypal is because
web is really our desktop of the future.
I think every battle that's gonna happen
including the
one with FCC, is gonna happen about the
web, right?
Make the web accessible, keep the, you
know, flow of information going.
and, and the web is so important.
So this is why it's so important for all
of us to keep web healthy, and
for you guys as developers and people who
design interfaces to be doctors of the
web.
>> Find key, key note.
Stanford's voice over off.
>> Okay [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay.
I'm going to begin with a small world
story.
Prior to working at Facebook, I worked at
Stanford
University as a Web accessibility
consultant on Scott Stockers team.
So I want to shout out a thanks to him.
For connecting us to the right people to
make this happen.
And I want to thank Michael Bernstein for
letting
us present here, although none of us have
our PhDs.
So I'd like to talk super fast because
we're running out of time.
For the next five minutes I'm gonna give
you a crash course on web accessibility.
You'll all be Web-X utility experts at the
end of five minutes
and then since today is all about acronyms
we saw pour and soap.
I'm gonna leave you with an acronym which
will
help you recall all the basic principles
of Web-X utility.
I'm gonna try to do live demo with
voice-overs so let's see how this goes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Comment tab to get to the?
>> Yes.
[NOISE]
>> Just while we're waiting so you guys
know that I remember.
>> [LAUGH].
>> [INAUDIBLE] Operable, understandable
and rumor.
>> [LAUGH].
[INAUDIBLE]
What if this is
out of you know
what that [INAUDIBLE]
just
Command Alt Delete.
So much for making this fast, okay, lets.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH] Okay.
>> [INAUDIBLE] You should turn on this
screen.
>> Yes we are fumbling through this, okay,
yeah.
It's, resisting to jump out of keynote.
And.
Yeah.
No, I don't, [UNKNOWN]
so well.
Okay.
>> Welcome to Safari accessibility 1 0 1.
Accessibility 1 0 1 html.
>> Move over, Donald.
Okay, let's get started.
I'm gonna work you through the basic
principles of
accessibility and also try to relate them
to design.
So I'll start with headings.
We all understand why headings are
important for visual design.
They help visually organize the content on
the website.
So it's really easy to glance at the
headings
and know what a website is trying to
convey.
With headings as Victor demonstrated they
are crucial
for accessibility because a person using a
screen reader
is going to try to get the gist
of a website just by jumping through the
headings.
So, let's take a look at that with
voiceover.
I don't where [UNKNOWN] school [UNKNOWN]
at CNN.com, but I'm [INAUDIBLE].
>> Voice-over on Safari accessibility 101
Window, Accessibility Heading Level one.
Headings and Semantic Markup.
>> I'm just gonna jump to the headings.
>> Heading Level two.
Like this heading.
Heading Level two.
And this one.
>> Okay the next two headings are
marked up using this, and not semantic
[INAUDIBLE].
>> You are currently on heading level two,
inside of html.
Muting.
They're marked up with those and not
semantic H two tabs
and you'll notice that voice over always
skips these two headings.
Lat heading heading, level two and this
one, voice over off.
>> So that's why it's really important to
mark up your headings with semantic H
tabs.
The next I'll have here is a set of form
fields.
The first set of form fields I've
associated
the labels with the form fields with
semantic markup.
That's a label with the for attribute
pointing to the text field.
And the next set of form fields, I
don't have the labels associated with the
text fields.
That's un-semantic markup.
So let's see what works with this.
>> Voice over on.
Safari, accessibility one, zero, one,
window, interact with
accessibility one, zero, one, H-T-M-L
content heading level one.
Semantic markup can't interact with
heading level one.
Semantic mark [SOUND] name, name, edit
text.
>> Okay, it announced the label for the
field, which is name.
[NOISE] I'm trying to tab to the next
field, so what do,
do I need to do anything to tab to the
next text field.
It's not tabbing when I tab to it.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay.
So the original demo was a lot more
obvious because when you
tab to the fields, Voice Over will
announce the name of the field.
But I'm just going to try to move through
each element now.
>> Voice Over on sa, address.
Edit text.
>> So Voice Over announces the label,
which is address.
>> Telephone.
Edit text.
Okay, now I'm gonna jump to the
un-semantic markup.
>> [SOUND] Edit text blank.
>> So.
[SOUND] Edit text blank.
>> So that's why semantic markup is
important.
>> Voiceover off.
>> Jumping to the next principle.
It's image is a non text content.
I have here a few screen shots from
popular web applications like Gmail and
Microsoft Word.
And the reason I've called them out here
is, it's not clear to me what
these icons indicate until I activate
them, and look at the options in the menu.
The third screen shot here is from the
Amazon mobile app.
The icons are really clear.
And there's text right below the icons.
Which makes it obvious what the icons
stand for.
Now, if web icons are confusing for a
sighted person-.
It's creates a really painful experience
for some one using
a screen reader, because now they would
have to tap to
the icon, activate it, and then go through
a list of
options in the menu to know what the icon
is representing.
So, let's look at a demo.
I have two images here.
The first image, I've associate it, with
some textual description.
And I do this by using the Alt attribute
in the image stack.
And, the first image is without the old
attribute.
And the second image, I associated with an
Alt attribute.
And let's see what voiceover does, when I
navigate to these two images.
>> Voiceover on Safari.
Interact with the, 1271084 underline,
10152203108461729
underline, 809245696 underline o.png
image.
>> So that's an image without an Alt text.
[LAUGH].
>> The Facebook logo image voice-over off.
>> Okay, so that's short and sweet, and
this is an easy problem
to fix most times, but this is actually
pretty prevalent on the web.
There are a bunch of images on the web
that don't
have text associated with them and they're
inaccessible to screen readers.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Okay, you hit the nail on the head.
So, I'm gonna, I'm gonna call [INAUDIBLE]
to sign off [INAUDIBLE].
The third basic principle, is keyboard
navigation.
What you see here is actually the
screenshot
of her design document from the sales
force log.
I thought this was interesting because it
was
a design document calling out desktops and
keyboard navigation.
But keyboard navigation is also crucial to
accessibility because
a person using a screen reader, as well as
those
with motor disabilities who cannot use a
mouse, use
just their keyboard to interact with
elements on the page.
So let's look at a demo of this.
Basic elements like links, buttons, and
form
fields which are marked up with semantic
markup.
Get keyboard focus by default when you
type it in.
But things get interesting when you build
custom widgets, and they're built with
unsemantic markers.
Like this big button I have here.
So let's look at this [CROSSTALK]
>> Voiceover on.
Safari.
Interact with accessibility once you're.
Link.
Focus buttons.
Button.
Text field.
Contents selected.
Form field.
Text fake button.
Clickable.
>> Okay.
>> Voiceover off.
>> This demo did not work, because I was
supposed to tap the fake button.
And one server would not have tabbed to
it,
but something is broken with the tab
navigation right now.
And so it did announce the name of the
button, but if you actually build buttons
with just divs
or spans and you're trying to tab to them,
the
screen reader is not going to tab to those
elements.
And we'll see in a few minutes how to make
this fake button accessible.
But before that my last principle, this is
a little bit of love.
For the sides to be compelling and
for them to create delightful experience
to users,
we have to meet and exceed users
expectations, and the same is true for
accessibility.
In addition to focusing on headings,
keyboard navigation, and non text content.
We also have to augment out HTML document
with some additional attributes, that
convey this extra information to screen
leaders, and that is done with ARIA.
ARIA stands for Accessible Rich Internet
Applications.
And it's a set of rules, states, and
properties that you
can associate with an HTML element to talk
to the screen reader.
So,
for, in order to make this fake button
accessible,
I would actually give it an ARIA rule of
button.
This tells the screen reader, that this
element is actually a button.
To make it get that focus when you talk to
it,
I need to add a tab index of zero to it,
and I also need to make sure that it
interacts to
key, with keyboard errands, just like it
does with mouse errands.
So, let's take a look at this with
voiceover.
>> Voiceover on Safari.
Interact with accessibility.
And fake button, button.
>> Okay.
>> You are currently on the button inside
java script I only respond to.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I was supposed to show you that
but I pressed enter with the keyboard but
some things up with the keyboard
navigation so I have to use the mouse to.
so I cheated, but you have to seen this
nice dialogue, it's hard work with just a
keyboard.
Getting back to Michael's question, are
just really easy if all access
of probability problems were are simple to
fix as we saw in these few examples.
But, we also want those situations where
you have to
be a bit clever about finding solutions to
your problems.
And I wanted to show you an example of
where we've done that.
And that is with Facebook photos.
We have billions of users and rated photos
from people all around the world on
Facebook.
And we can force people all around the
world to
always enter the caption or an on text for
their photo.
So to solve this problem we built
something called the caption generator.
The caption generator takes bits of
metadata
associated with the photo, who uploaded
the
photo, where was the photo uploaded, who
are the people tagged in the photo.
And it generates a caption or an alt text
for the image, which we then associate
with the image.
So when, when someone lands on the photo
it, it announces this nice caption for the
photo.
And, I don't know if you have time for
the-
>> Yes.
>> Video, okay.
>> Yes
>> So let's take a look at a video showing
also while interrupting photo's, you'll
notice that
before we have played the captions and
data also we're also generating some like
linked image when we adapt a photo.
And after we apply the caption generator
it announces the matching description for
the photos.
[SOUND].
[BLANK_AUDIO].
>> Link.
[SOUND].
[SOUND]
[BLANK_AUDIO].
Cover photo.
Clint Andrew hall's photo taken at
coliseum titled nighttime shot of the
coliseum.
Link image.
Profile image of Clint Andrew Hall, link
image.
Link.
Clint Andrew Hall's photo, of Clint Andrew
Hall and Art [UNKNOWN] taken
at aircraft carrier US..S Hornet, entitled
on the dock outside the USS Hornet.
Such an amazing place.
Link image.
Clint Andrew Hall's photo taken at
aircraft
carrier U.S.S. Hornet entitled "Outside
the Party."
Link image.
Clint Andrew Hall's photo taken at
aircraft carrier U.S.S.
Hornet entitled "The Passenger Receipt was
a Nice Touch."
Everyone kept asking if the bar code was
real.
Link image.
>> Okay.
That's all I had, I'm now gonna hand it
over to Jeff.
He's gonna talk about making Access really
mainstream.
>> We end at 2:05, is that right?
[NOISE]
>> Would you prefer to do questions, or
should I just keep going?
>> This is your call.
If you want to do five minutes of
questions, or people can stay after.
>> Do you guys have questions?
I mean, I'm happy to do some now.
>> I'm even free [INAUDIBLE].
>> Sure.
>> okay, so presentation is supposed end
with, a couple of quick stories.
Let me just give you one quick story then.
I wanna try to answer this question, which
is why are we really here?
Why would Facebook and PayPal excited
to come Stanford and talk about
accessibility?
And the story that I think captures that
best is a story that starts on Facebook.
I want to introduce you to a front end
engineer named Jason.
He is in his late 20's he graduated from
Carnegie Mellon University
he's about to get married in two weeks,
he's a very nice guy.
He was working on a product called web
messenger.
Web messenger is if you use Facebook in a
desktop browser and you send messages.
That's Jason's product.
So, when he was working on Web Messenger
about a
year ago, we were doing a large refresh to
this product.
I noticed that there were gonna be some
challenges with,
with it regards to accessibility and
compatibility in a screen reader.
So I reached out to Jason, and I asked
him, have you
tested this product for accessibility and
he tested it in a screen reader.
Jason's response was.
What's a screen reader.
This is one of the dreaded response that
you get if somebody's working
accessibility, when you reach out to an
engineer and you ask them to,
you know, are they working on
accessibility for their product and their
response
is, I really don't know anything about
accessibility or what a screen reader is.
So despite the fact that Jason had
graduated from you know, an outstanding
engineering program.
Had past the technical part to work on the
front end of Facebook he had no exposure
to accessibility.
And I'm not here to push Jason under the
bus, I really don't think this is Jason's
fault.
[COUGH]
>> And in fact, most of the engineers that
we
work with at Facebook have a similar
experience as Jason.
They have not been exposed to
accessibility in their training.
And so, I think it's a little bit
difficult
to expect that the web is going to be
accessible.
If the people who are building the
web, don't have much understanding about
accessibility.
So one of the reasons why we were really
excited
to come here, was just to connect with
students like you
guys working in design, HCI and computer
science who are
ultimately going to build the future web
and build future products.
We want you guys to know, earlier, in the
process in your life cycles as developers
and as creators
about accessibility so that you can demand
it, from the
products that you're building, and you
know what to do.
You have some best practices.
I know that Rommy moved pretty quickly
through some of the HTML demonstrations,
but-.
>> [UNKNOWN] [FOREIGN].
So that's the acronym.
[LAUGH]
>> Just remember for next time that you
are
working with a web team or building a web
product.
[COUGH]
>> And that's, If you know those things
you can build a more accessible
experience and that's really what it's
gonna
take, i's gonna take a scaled approach
to this, not just a handful of companies
trying to solve this but everyone
who's building the web to understand more
about this, and to know what to do.
I'll end there.
If we have you know, some time for
questions we're happy to stay for a little
bit.
But thank you very much for your time.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
[SOUND]